wow sweet setup what do you make here
don't worry about it oh cool cool cool
cool cool cool
so uh so we can add things now yeah why
not right I mean we got the time and we
got the ink everything but the Cajun
sang what did I just say and that is
under Charles
back to the window get back in the
window so how was your night of work I'm
not asking about your personal life I
don't care about you personally I mean
I'm neutral I mean who are you
floundering is worse than silence
yeah this elevator's slow huh Great rule
number three let's not have sex right
away
cool cool cool cool cool
no doubt no doubt no doubt no doubt good
rule no sex good rule hey Sharon how are
you doing vaginally what don't ask her
that okay Jake all you have to do is
keep her comfortable I'm on my way okay
sounds good and do you want to just meet
us at the hospital
okay got it got it cool cool no hospital
I am picking up what you're screaming
down you may get painful going to like
swelling in your neck and often extreme
testicular discomfort
the one dumb wedding thing I've always
wanted was a bachelorette party ah so
cool cool all the pressures on that one
event cool cool very cool no problem I
don't need your ID Federal database is
done anyway wink wink huh so how do you
like your ammo by the boxer by the
bucket cool cool cool our country is
broken what if he isn't taking his
medicine you could mix it in with his
food sorry you can deal with your sick
dog later Boyle well actually that was
about my son nikolaj he's got allergies
I think we may have to go with the nasal
douche ah nasal douche very gross I'm
gonna catch this last fugitive win the
bet and then we're gonna live together
for the rest of our relationship just
you and me and towel makes three cool
cool cool cool cool cool hey Bronte
how's it going man pretty good thanks
for asking ooh cool cool so how's it
going I'm still pretty good okay okay
this is
really bad but just remember we are not
going to jail we didn't do it we're
innocent guilty on all charges
very cool
cool cool cool cool cool cool cool cool
cool
cool so does this mean that I'm part of
the crew nobody can touch you now wow I
guess all it took was the ramen tip
actually you gotta do one more thing for
me to close the deal absolutely no
problem I actually have a great idea for
a Ramen dessert you make it with Jello
mix I need you to kill a guard
okay great
beef babies out for blood
so ah those are our stolen shoes but
who's Miss BK sneaks her name is Jenny
McFadden she moves her merch out of the
back of a bodega on Willoughby cool wait
a Boomer's not doing it who's running
the task force detective Brett Booth
from 6'3
I can't believe we thought we were gonna
make it so what are you been up to man
well I'm still trying to get the music
thing started oh cool cool never give up
so
so so
Roses by yes Jake I remember
yeah stay man great thanks
oh yeah
hi there who are you and why are you
following me I'm not following you
I come for Charles Boyle
hey hey hands where we can see him
shallots bro it's not gun it's just uh
it's a toy I'm not sure pretty place
it's gift
for Nicholas Nicholas how do you know
Charles's son my name is gintas from
Latvia
I am Nicolas
oh nikolaj's birth father who I never
hope to meet very cool cool cool
hey by the way we don't have to pretend
we're undercover here the
hospital setting up cover was it well
just the kids thing saying that we were
gonna start trying soon oh I'm sorry I
didn't mean right away I just meant in
the near future oh
Okay Google
this side of the room lunch is on me and
we're getting something better than
pizza sushi
are you trying to outdo me no no
just trying to raise morale
cool cool cool cool morale morale morale
okay that's it Debbie Fogle you are
under arrest what oh my God are you not
really dirty no and I'll be taking that
gun
foreign
have given Debbie superpowers
Oh indeed indeed indeed indeed that's
weird look Raymond a yellow crested
warbler yes that's the right level of
excitement for such a bird you've
captured the essence of Kevin you've
done it correction I've accomplished it
indeed indeed indeed indeed indeed
indeed
it's growing on me foreign